[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de face aux territoires avec nos
partenaires co producteurs habituels
ouest france vous pouvez regarder cette
émission d'ailleurs sur ouest france.fr
en direct sur nicematin.com et sur
franceantilles.fr en léger décalage
horaire du bien sûr aux fuseaux aux
antilles mon invité ce matin on est ravi
de l'accueillir c'est le président du
comité d'organisation des jeux
olympiques et paralympiques paris 2024
c'est tony estanguet bonjour thoniers
scandé bonjour ici d'être avec nous j'ai
regardé dans votre biographie vous avez
été porte-drapeau à pékin 2008 il n'y a
pas si longtemps vous connaissez bien
les chinois bien sûr ces jeux de pékin
vont être boycottés diplomatiquement par
les pays anglo saxons en tout cas
l'angleterre les états unis et
l'australie la chine a répondu ce matin
que ces pays en paieront le prix
qu'est-ce qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette tension voilà quelques à quelques
jours maintenant de ces jo de pékin vous
qui connaissait bien oui alors c'est
vrai que le sujet il existait déjà en
2008 manquant j'étais porte-drapeau
effectivement je me souviens qu'il avait
déjà ses appels au boycott la france
n'avaient pas boycotté d'ailleurs elle
n'a jamais boycotté les jeux
depuis depuis que pierre de coubertin
les à rénover et moi je pense qu'il faut
il faut laisser l'enjeu diplomatique se
dérouler et il faut aussi préserver le
monde du sport il ya des discussions
vous allez au milieu de discussions non
moi je n'ai pas un mec est normalement
avec non sur ses investitures et dans
ces discussions c'est vraiment vous
pourriez parce que vous avez une la
phrase est d'ailleurs vrai sens de se
positionner elle a décidé d'ailleurs de
se positionner avec l'union européenne
que je trouve sage c'est bien d'avoir
une position collective sur ce sujet
voilà moi personnellement vous
connaissez ma position je suis plutôt
contre le boycott sportif je pense qu'on
a besoin du sport on a besoin des
valeurs du sport on a besoin que cette
jeunesse dans le monde entier elles sont
inspirées par ses athlètes il faut pas
mélanger les enjeux politiques et les
enjeux sportifs ça ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas d'autre moyen de mettre
la pression sur
encore une fois sur la diplomatie mais
n'utilisons pas les sportifs pour régler
des enjeux dit est ce que je pense vous
père chinois vous parler avec eux les
sportifs chinois de de cette crise quand
même politique certes sur les vidéos oui
ben ça souvent entre sportifs nous on
n'a pas envie de se retrouver mêlé dans
encore une fois des enjeux politiques
qui dépassent le monde du sport et on
demande souvent au monde du sport de
régler ces enjeux là et finalement
d'être les victimes un peu
collatéral d'enjeux qui dépasse bien
évidemment le monde du sport donc je
pense à mon jeu je prône le fait que les
jeux olympiques restent préservés de ces
enjeux là je suis pas dupe je suis pas
naïf je sais qu'il ya des enjeux
politiques autour de ça mais n'allons
pas trop loin et personnellement je suis
contre le boycott voilà tony estanguet
président du comité d'organisation des
jeux olympiques et paralympiques de
paris 2024 et notre invité pendant 40
minutes en direct sur tv5 monde dont
dans 200 pays et en 14 langues dans un
instant françois-xavier le franc de
ouest france nous rejoint sur ce plateau
bonjour françois xavier le franc jeu de
ouest france on le rappelle premier
quotidien francophone du monde et nous
allons interviewé tony a scandé sur sur
les territoires parce que oui hôpital
c'est le thème de cette émission alors
tony estanguet bonjour vous êtes à la
tête d'un événement qui va voir
évidemment rayonnement mondial et vous
êtes on le dit l'homme d'un territoire
auquel vous êtes fidèles le béarn votre
béarn vous avez toujours dit que c'est
je devais être aussi les jeux des
territoires et quand vous le dit on vous
croit parce que vous êtes sincère sur ce
sujet là c'est pas ce n'est pas une
posture alors concrètement comment faire
pour que ce grand rendez-vous rayonne
sur tous les territoires français y en a
beaucoup l'hexagone l'outre-mer jusque
dans chaque village vous avez dit même
exactement c'est vrai que le défi pour
nous c'est de réussir à ce que ce rendez
vous avec le monde il ya quatre
milliards de personnes qui vont regarder
la france en 2024 on va accueillir 206
pays avec 15 mille athlètes voilà qui
vont représenter le monde du sport
c'était important pour nous de
d'associer de valoriser l'ensemble des
territoires français à la réussite de
cet événement pourquoi parce que nous
sportifs de haut niveau nous venons des
quatre coins de la france nous avons
commencé le sport dans des petits clubs
dans des petites villes ou des grandes
villes d'ailleurs mais alors on a envie
de valoriser ce que la france du sport
le mouvement sportif français fort de
ses 180 mille clubs de sport apporte à
notre société moi je suis convaincu
qu'on doit renforcer la place du sport
dans notre pays est la seule manière de
le faire c'est de réussir à embarquer
tout ce mouvement sportif dans tous les
territoires concrètement comment ça va
se passer il y aura évidemment des
délégations qui vont être répartis sur
les territoires il y aura aussi des des
événements enfin décidé de compétition
des sites qui vont être également
répartie sur les territoires comment
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus oui
alors voilà en fait l'idée c'est à 360°
de réussir justement avoir cette
ouverture des jeux de paris 2024 à
l'ensemble de la france ce sera le cas
pour les compétitions puisqu'on aura des
compétitions qui vont organiser un peu
partout en france et d'ailleurs en
outre-mer pu notamment sur les épreuves
de de surf qui seront organisées sur la
vague mythique haïti tahiti à tubes mais
on aura voilà des villes non de bordeaux
2 nice de marseille de saint-etienne de
lyon de lille qui vont accueillir des
compétitions pendant les jeux on voit
que certaines installations d'ailleurs
où d'ailleurs ça va ça nécessité
d'énormes travaux bien sûr alors pas
forcément il ya des aménagements mais on
a plutôt un concept qui s'appuie sur 95%
des infrastructures qui sont déjà
existantes en est allé à des endroits où
les infrastructures sont déjà existant
parce que la france elle est forte aussi
de sa richesse d'équipements sportifs
partout en région on imagine que
beaucoup de maires beaucoup de
collectivités locales territoriales sont
attentives au sujet et ont envie de
exactement en fait on s'est rendu compte
que ça ne suffisait pas cette dimension
des compétitions ne suffisait pas et
donc on a créé pour la première fois
dans l'histoire des jeux ce programme
terre de jeux 2024 pour permettre à
l'ensemble des communes et l'ensemble
des clubs de sport partout dans le
territoire d'être associés au jeu pour
la première fois le cio a accepté que ce
label terre de jeux 2024 existent pour
venir valoriser toutes les villes
villages villes métropoles départements
régions et tous les clubs de sport qui
veulent participer à faire plus de sport
aux français parce que l'héritage de
parts et 2024 il doit permettre que les
français fassent plus de sport
aujourd'hui on a une statistique avec
laquelle on n'est pas à l'aise ya un
français sur deux qui ne fait pas de
sport comment est ce qu'on arrive à
aller gratter grâce à un process défilé
s'est s'allié fiege otaries et de
trouver dans les trois prochaines années
des solutions pour que partout en france
on puisse faire faire du sport aux
français aux jeunes ou moins jeunes et
valoriser ceux qui jouent le jeu avec ce
label terre de jeux 2004 on a déjà plus
de 2000 communes donc 91 département 13
régions qui sont labellisés terre de jeu
et qui permettent aux français chaque
année de faire des événements de
rencontrer les athlètes et quelque part
de donner envie aux gens de faire du
sport avec tous les français impliqués
on va parler des jeux paralympiques
également tony estanguet vous êtes le
président du comité des jeux olympiques
et paralympiques et la semaine dernière
la secrétaire d'état aux personnes
handicapées sophie cluzel était présente
sur notre plateau la veille du téléthon
et
la journée mondiale des personnes
handicapées c'était c'était le lendemain
également et là une question à vous
poser elle nous parlait d'ailleurs de
ceux auxquels elle croit pour cgo de
barrie on les écoute comment on fait que
l'accessibilité universelle et pensé par
ton je crois beaucoup aux jeux
olympiques et paralympiques pour
améliorer l'accessibilité vont tenir
votre place jeudi prochain un bas très
bien je le salue d'avancé c'est un
combat de tous le temps pensé accepté
universel vous avez tout à fait raison
alors comment comment faire pour que ces
jeux donc les jeux paralympiques c'est
évidemment beaucoup d'épreuves très
organisé ce sera dans la foulée d'aidé
de la première première partie comment
faire pour que au quotidien dans le
monde du sport en france au quotidien
l'accès des handicapés soient facilitées
soit améliorée soit naturel qui est pas
toujours ses difficultés
c'est une question très importante pour
nous et c'était un défi d'abord domo sur
les jeux paralympiques c'est un
événement qui est méconnu qui est
absolument incroyable d'un point de vue
sportif aujourd'hui le niveau sportif
des jeux paralympiques il est
extraordinaire et il faut vraiment
s'intéresser valoriser ces athlètes
paralympiques qui ont des histoires de
vie incroyable qui s'entraînent tous les
jours dans des situations des fois un
peu compliqué et qui arrivent à faire
des choses vraiment d'un point de vue
sportif qui sont magiques c'est pour ça
que le comité d'organisation que je
préside a décidé vraiment de mettre le
niveau d'ambition très haut sur ces jeux
paralympiques avec une grosse attente
des pouvoirs publics vous avez entendu
la secrétaire d'état vient évidemment
elle a raison ce cette notion
d'accessibilité universelle elle éclaire
notre comité d'organisation va créer une
norme iso pour faire en sorte que le
milieu de l'événementiel prennent en
compte à toutes les dimensions cette
logique d'accessibilité ça veut dire
accéder à l'information quel que soit
son type de handicap accéder au site et
tous les sites de compétition à la fois
olympiques et paralympiques seront
accessibles par des transports justement
publiques qui seront accessibles et on
va multiplier comme cela les engagements
pour proposer un événement beaucoup plus
accessible beaucoup plus inclusif en
matière de marché en matière d'emploi
mais au-delà de ça en matière d'héritage
aujourd'hui le défi c'est de multiplier
les structures qui peuvent accueillir
ces personnes en situation de handicap
donc en a mis en place des formes des
formations notamment à paris avec anne
hidalgo la maire de paris on a fait en
sorte que des clubs qui aujourd'hui
n'ont pas de section par à sport pour
accueillir ces personnes en situation de
handicap puissent voir le jour et on est
en train d'étendre ce dispositif en
seine saint denis et on l'espère par
tout temps donc avec les territoires
c'est l'autre grand défi des jeux de
paris exactement les territoires doivent
se s'approprier cette question de
l'inclusion du paralympiques mme terre
de jeux 2024 à cette dimension on
organise chaque année la semaine
olympique et paralympique dans les
écoles avec deux tiers des projets qui
sont sur cette logique du handisport du
para sport c'est à dire avoir ce regard
qui évoluent sur le handicap bien
souvent les personnes en situation de
handicap pense qu'elles n'ont pas accès
aux pratiques du sport parce que ya pas
de pratiques sportives qui sont
accessibles et ce n'est pas le cas et au
passage il faut aussi que les médias les
médias dans le monde entier s'intéresse
autant aux sports aux handisports que
qu'au sport merci merci de le dire ou ce
dont on a besoin de vous on a besoin le
monde des médias ce s'approprie
davantage les jeux paralympiques c'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui il ya trop de
différences entre le traitement
médiatique des jeux olympiques le
traitement médiatique des jeux
paralympiques il faut vraiment qu'on
arrive à mieux faire connaître les
athlètes et les paras sport et bien
justement tony estanguet qui est notre
invité aujourd'hui morgan legrand qui
est une mal voyantes qui est animatrice
d'une émission qui s'appelle dans les
yeux de morgan / tv 78 une chaîne des
yvelines partenaires de notre émission
thierry barbedette son directeur général
est d'ailleurs présent sur ce plateau
est là une question à vous poser sur un
autre type d'accessibilité au lait coûte
j'ai une question pour vous dans ce
contexte de préparation des jeux
olympiques et paralympiques
comment pourrait-on selon vous
démocratiser l'accès au sport pour des
personnes en situation de handicap qui
ont précisément des problématiques de
santé ou de rééducation que l'on connaît
c'est vraiment la question c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui l'offre sportive elle
doit être pensée pour tous et c'est ça
le vrai défi c'est que il faut casser
cette barrière souvent les personnes en
situation de handicap se disent je ne
peux pas je n'ai pas accès je n'ai pas
les moyens de pouvoir aller trouver un
club dans lequel je serai bien intégré
donc nous on a mis en place ces
formations encore une fois pour que les
dirigeants des clubs se sentent aussi
plus prêt s'adresse pas simplement même
aux sportifs handicapés déjà très fort
non c'est parce qu'il s'agit de le faire
pour tout le monde a envie qu'ils ont
jamais fait et ça doit commencer dès le
plus jeune âge c'est pourtant celle que
à l'école déjà on arrive à ce que cette
notion de handicap qui a quand même un
peu tendu au tabou encore dans notre
pays elle soit posée et c'est vrai que
la pratique d'un sport elle permet tout
de suite de mettre les gens à l'aise et
de partage parce que on l'a dit il ya
une semaine le handicap chez des jeunes
et notamment chez des jeunes adultes
c'est parfois des situations de solitude
très douloureuse et le sport le sport
permet l'inclusion se permet de rendre
faire lui permet de prendre du plaisir
elles permettent finalement de rendre
les choses possibles quand on fait du
sport même quand on est en situation de
handicap on découvre de nouveaux
horizons et on prend confiance en soi
donc c'est vraiment important qu'on
arrive collectivement à trouver de
solutions aussi pour ça que terre de
jeux 2024 aussi est très important pour
nous pour que l'ensemble des territoires
développe l'offre sportive pour les
personnes en situation de handicap tony
estanguet vous avez été entendu on vient
d'apprendre à l'instant que la france ne
participera pas au boycott c'était votre
souhait est bien le gouvernement vient
de confirmer ça me dit on à l'instant
françois-xavier le franc il s'agit aussi
de parler un peu de la place du sport
amateur capitale oui le sport amateur il
s'est un peu réveillée groggy de la
deûle après la pandémie ya des clubs qui
ont souffert financièrement qu'ils n'ont
pas pu organiser des événements qui
permettait d'avoir un petit peu de
moyens alors ces clubs ils ont besoin
évidemment de se relancer les jeux
olympiques c'est un formidable moment
alors certains vous diront va à nouveau
dépenser beaucoup d'argent pour des
grandes compétitions comment associer
pleinement vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure chaque club amateur avec tous
ces bénévoles qui font un boulot
formidable
comment faire en sorte que ce grand
événement mondial auprès de chacun des
clubs amateurs et notamment de ceux qui
aujourd'hui ont du mal sur les
territoires associer des jeunes parce
qu'il ya parfois la désertification qui
fait que les clubs ont du mal à vivre
comment insuffler un véritable esprit
jo-2000 24 dans tous ses clubs à nous en
fait depuis le début quand même un
normalement le rôle d'un comité
d'organisation c'est d'organiser des
compétitions en 2024 depuis le début on
s'est dit le défi de paris me lever 4
c'est d'avoir effectivement la réussite
de l'événement mais c'est aussi
l'héritage qu'est ce qui reste de tout
ça est notre héritage principal c'est un
héritage immatériel c'est pas le nombre
de stades qu'on va construire mais c'est
comment est-ce qu'il ya plus de français
qui font du sport et comment en le
troisième défi c'est comment on engage
le plus grand nombre donc comment est-ce
qu'on accompagne des clubs qui
effectivement joue ce rôle prépondérant
quelque part de la réussite du mouvement
sportif en france en les valorisant moi
j'ai besoin aujourd'hui mon valorise
davantage ce qu'un club de sport rapport
sur un territoire c'est de l'éducation
c'est la santé aujourd'hui on avec cette
pandémie on voit bien que le meilleur
moyen et ce à toutes les études
scientifiques le démontre le meilleur
moyen de vivre en bonne santé et
longtemps c'est de pratiquer
régulièrement une activité sportive est
le meilleur espace pour pratiquer une
activité sportive en sécurité c'est le
club donc si vous voulez faire du sport
aller dans un club et c'est là que vous
trouverez les meilleurs conseils et la
meilleure manière de faire du sport
justement armelle le goff qui dit
l'actrice de la rédaction de 20 minutes
à une question à vous poser à ce sujet
sur la transmission de valeurs
citoyennes dans le sport bonjour tony
estanguet le sport est un vecteur des
valeurs citoyennes pourtant on voit
beaucoup de violence aujourd'hui dans le
monde du sport beaucoup de violence dans
les stades alors on s'interroge n'y at
il pas un problème de transmission des
valeurs sportives actuellement ne
faudrait-il pas mettre un terme à cette
violence avant paris 2024 il faut mettre
un terme à cette violence après c'est
sûr que la violence n'a pas sa place il
faut être beaucoup plus ferme sur les
sanctions dans des cas de violence parce
que c'est intolérable et ça vient
effectivement polluée toutes les valeurs
de respect autour de autour du sport et
est le meilleur remède face à ça c'est
aussi la formation il faut qu'on arrive
à
à former les structures associatives les
dirigeants les volontaires qui accueille
aussi et les supporters on a un travail
voilà on espère qu'il y aura des
milliers des millions de supporters
derrière les équipes de france en 2024
il faut qu'on crée une image très
festive on va accueillir le monde et on
espère vraiment effectivement qu'il n'y
ait pas de violence qui ne doit pas
avoir sa place dans le monde du sport
françois vivier le franches au nuc est
un collaborateur et dessinateur de ouest
france une question à poser à tony
estanguet sous forme de dessin c'est une
tradition ouest france dans cette
émission la géopolitique saint vit
toujours dans les jeux olympiques on le
voit avec le possible boycott des jeux
d'hiver en chine tony estanguet vous
vous avez pris en main l'organisation
des jeux de paris en 2024 vous êtes né à
pau patrie d'henri iv et pour
paraphraser le roi le plus populaire de
l'histoire de france paris vaut bien des
jeux réussis bien justement j'en viens à
ma question comment faire pour que les
travaux d'aménagement ne fasse pas vivre
aux franciliennes et aux franciliens un
calvaire supplémentaires eux qui tous
les jours subissent l'enfer des
embouteillages alors quelque chose me
dit
que vous avez des idées
en matière de fluidification
du trafic
on n'avait pas alors qu'il en aurait non
c'était d'avoir un mot sur les travaux
parce que c'est vrai que encore une fois
le concept de paris 2004 c'est de ne pas
construire de stade qui ne vont pas
laisser un héritage long terme dont 95%
des équipements sont déjà construits et
la soli deo qui est la société de
livraison des ouvrages olympique elle
met en place vraiment des mesures très
fortes pour réduire les nuisances sur le
bruit on va utiliser la scène
chaque fois qu'on utilise une barge pour
les travaux ces 220 lyon 2 - qui
transitent sur les routes parisiennes
donc là on tout est mis en place
aujourd'hui pour réduire les nuisances
la une de ouest france françois xavier
le franc est bien c'est un projet
mondial dans lequel vont travailler
ensemble les etats-unis la russie la
chine l'union européenne la corée du sud
et le japon ça fait rêver tony estanguet
c'est les jeux olympiques de l'énergie
demain c'est le projet iter en provence
et on est allé en reportage là bas un
projet exceptionnel avec un aimant qui
sera le plus gros du monde et qui
paraît-il pourrait soulever un sous
marin c'est aussi avec soin merci
françois xavier le franc ou ouest france
vous êtes le rédacteur en chef du plus
grand quotidien français plus grands
quotidiens de langue francophone au
monde merci dans un instant denis
carrosse de nice matin sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour denis carot dans un instant je
vous laisserai tony estanguet le
président du comité d'organisation des
jeux olympiques et paralympiques paris
2024 pour l'instant on va se rendre du
côté des antilles à fort-de-france en
duplex avec cyril gautier le directeur
éditorial de france antilles quelques
questions à vous poser tony estanguet
l'écoutent
bonjour tony estanguet les outre-mers
vont être présentés lors des jo au pari
de 1024 notamment en polynésie où se
dérouleront les épreuves de surf mais en
amont de ces jo les territoires
d'outre-mer peuvent aussi avoir une
carte à jouer notamment lors de la
préparation des champions je pense
notamment aux champions en titre huiyan
est en un tennis mme est il envisageable
que qu'un certain nombre de stages de
préparation puisse se dérouler dans nos
territoires
quand en martinique en guadeloupe qu'en
guyane en vue des jo c'est effectivement
un des enjeux pour nous encore une fois
on voulait absolument valoriser ces
territoires et régions d'outre-mer qui
participe au rayonnement du sport
français ce sont souvent des pourvoyeurs
de médailles françaises tous les grands
champions beaucoup de grands champions
viennent de ces territoires là donc pour
la première fois on l'a réussi à les
associer à une organisation et ce sera
le cas pour le surf et pour la
préparation effectivement mais on a pour
la polynésie et pour les antilles et la
guyane on a labellisé aujourd'hui huit
centres de préparation des jeux qu'on a
envoyé aux 206 pays qui vont participer
en 2024 pour leur dire si vous voulez et
vous préparer sur un territoire français
en amont des compétitions vous pouvez
aller dans ses 8 centres de préparation
aux antilles ou en guyane où vous
trouverez des installations de meilleurs
standards pour vous préparer sur
quelques sport trac la british mme de
nos départements exactement et valoriser
encore une fois tous ces territoires qui
aiment le sport qui est investi dans le
sport et et qui propose les meilleures
conditions de préparation la jeunesse
bonjour tony estanguet on va parler de
la jeunesse que vous avez envie
d'associer au maximum aux geo et et à
leur réussite vous le disiez tout à
l'heure on ne fait pas assez de sport en
france c'est particulièrement vrai pour
les jeunes d'après un classement de l'om
s en matière de pratique sportive des
jeunes on est classé en france en 16e
sur 149 est-ce que les géo peuvent
permettre d'inverser la tendance écoutez
moi je me suis gré construit grâce au
sport depuis le plus jeune âge les
études démontrent qu'un jeune qui n'a
pas fait de sport avant d'entrer en 6e
au collège
devient adulte sédentaire donc c'est une
tester une statistique qui fait peur il
faut vraiment agir sur
cette étape de l'école primaire pour
donner envie aux jeunes de faire du
sport tous les jours la clé l'om est la
clé c'est l'école la clé c'est l'école
dans un premier temps et l oms dit pour
être en bonne santé il faut pratiquer à
minima à cet âge là une heure d'activité
physique et sportive par jour et donc il
faut trouver dans le temps scolaire dans
l'organisation scolaire c'est trente
minutes que nous on prône avec le
ministère de l'éducation nationale on
invite vraiment tous les enseignants à
mettre en place cette mesure on a
développé des fiches thématiques clés en
main qui ont été faites par des athlètes
par des médecins par des scientifiques
par des professeurs aussi d'éducation
physique et sportive pour de manière
ludique faire en sorte que ces jeunes se
dépensent plus parce qu'un jeune qui se
dépense il est plus concentré ils
mangent mieux y dort mieux et du coup il
est plus épanouie ça tombe bien puisque
franck fernandes de nice matin denis
carot a rencontré youssef vous allez le
voir tony stark et qui a 10 ans il est
en cm2 il vit à nice bien sûr il ya une
question assez logique sur la situation
sanitaire l'écoutent
pour les jeux olympiques de 2024 est ce
que vous auriez une solution un plan b
si un confinement à cause du coût vide à
à sion logis merci youssef pour ta
question
c'est sûr qu'aujourd'hui on vit dans une
situation on voit bien qu'on est obligé
de s'adapter alors la bonne nouvelle
entre guillemets c'est que on a déjà
trouvé des solutions le monde du sport
il ya des plans b énoncer des adapteurs
aujourd'hui on voit bien que les matchs
se déroulent avec des stades pleins et
que c'est logique de passes annie terre
et de distanciation et de gestes
barrières qu'à un plan blanc pour les
bio on s'adaptera je pense qu'il est
trop tôt aujourd'hui pour définir le
plan précis de 2024 on observe
énormément tout ce qui a été mis en
place à tokyo et ce qui est mis en place
actuellement par les différents
événements ce qui est ce qui est la
bonne nouvelle c'est qu'on saura
s'adapter et que les joueurs eux
pourront se tenir encore une fois notre
ambition c'est que ces jeux soient très
populaire et que les gens aient accès et
puissent vivre cette fête là une de
keats matin dennis k o car vous avez un
magazine pour les enfants qui édite le
groupe nice matin le mercredi avec le
print mais en numérique oui et on parle
de sport justement du des championnats
du monde de handball féminin les équipes
de france et a eu la médaille d'or aux
jo de pékin et on explique à nos jeunes
lecteurs aux deux tokyo on explique à
nos jeunes lecteurs tout ce qu'il faut
savoir sur cette discipline est sûre
l'équipe de france j'y vois là et puis
le sport c'est aussi des emplois denis
carot c'est des emplois l'objectif c'est
de créer 150 mille emplois autour des jo
comment faire en sorte qu'il bénéficie
aux jeunes et notamment aux jeunes qui
n'ont pas accès à l'emploi actuellement
alors c'est vrai que ça aussi c'est
intéressant de le souligner en fait le
modèle économique des jeux déjà il est
financé à 98% par de l'argent privé donc
dans les prochaines années
les 4 milliards d'euros du comité
d'organisation du budget du comité
d'organisation sont financés par de
l'argent privé et ça va générer
effectivement voilà des dizaines de
milliers d'emplois autour de 150 mille
emplois seront mobilisés directement
pour l'organisation de ces jeux ce
qu'est ce qu'on a souhaité faire
remplacer justement faire cette
cartographie des emplois dès 2018 pour
identifier dans quel secteur d'activité
la restauration la sécurité la
construction
l'événementiel la communication donc
combien d'emplois dans chacun des
métiers seront ouverts ap pour paris
2024 il ya une transparence toutes les
offres d'emploi sont publiés sur notre
site internet donc donc on peut aller
les consulter dans n'hésitez pas il ya
déjà voilà la possibilité énormément
énormément chaque semaine on recrute en
lien avec par une 1024 triplé ces
emplois est ce que ça sera aussi dans
les territoires et pas uniquement en
région parisienne alors encore une fois
tout le monde peut accéder à ces emplois
le la plupart des emplois sont
effectivement travaillé à paris parce
que c'est là que le coeur du réacteur se
se trouvera mais on aura des emplois
aussi en région notamment aux proches
des sites de compétition et héros des
jeux écologiques c'est ça oui
vous souhaitez faire des jeux durable au
delà de la question des équipements des
infrastructures comment concrètement
vous ferez en sorte que ces jeux soient
respectueux de l'environnement dans
leurs organes y alors là aussi
l'ambition de par une 4 est très haute
puisqu'on est là on s'est engagé à
réduire de moitié les émissions carbone
généré à l'occasion des jeux par rapport
aux airs aux éditions précédentes donc
c'est un défi du quotidien en a mis en
place une procédure en interne pour
toutes les équipes de paris de 24,2 de
mesurer nos propres émissions tout au
long du dispositif et surtout de
sécuriser le fait qu' on réduise sur
chaque marché c'est à dire que dans les
critères de choix pour choisir un
prestataire on évalue encore une fois
l'impact carbone que ça va engendrer des
exemples concrets ça se traduit par par
quoi pas vraiment ça se traduit
notamment sûr on ne construit pas on
utilise l'existant au maximum tous les
sites seront
desservis par des transports en commun
accessible donc pour réduire signature
ces lieux vise à sion de la voiture on
multiplie aussi l'aller les moyens doux
pour se rendre sur les sites de
compétition avec ses ces voix de vélo
pour que tous les sites là aussi
puissent être desservis par des moyens
doux et donc c'est vraiment encore une
fois dans tous les sujets cette volonté
de d'économie circulaire pour réutiliser
l'existant faire en sorte qu'il y ait
une double une deuxième vie aussi après
les jeux pour que l'impact soit le
moindre possible et tony estanguet on
peut en témoigner venus en vélo en vélib
ce matin sur ce plateau dans ce studio
tv 60,18 notre partenaire à interviewer
laurent mazaury le vice-président de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines adjoint aux
sports qui a une question à vous poser
sur l'après jo tout le monde se pose des
questions aussi sur l'après on écoute
bonjour monsieur le président bonjour
tony estanguet nombreux sont les
commentateurs qui considère que nombre
des jeux olympiques par le passé se sont
soldées bien souvent par très peu de
bénéfices pour les populations locales
et par un certain nombre d'équipements
par exemple laissé à l'abandon
tous en tête les jeux olympiques
d'athènes par exemple et à la verse des
grands succès comme les jeux olympiques
de londres plus récemment je sais votre
engagement pour que les jeux olympiques
de paris 2024 soit un succès à la fois
d'un point de vue sportif pendant
l'événement mais également pour les
populations et pour le futur pouvez vous
nous dire quels sont vos ambitions en
matière d'héritage pour les jeux
olympiques de paris 2024 et je vous pose
cette question avec d'autant plus de
passion que je suis sur un territoire
celui de 50 ans divine qui accueillera à
lui tout seul quatre sites olympiques
quelles sont donc pour les populations
de nos territoires quels seront les
avantages d'accueillir chez aux
olympiques une fois que ceux-ci les
auront quitté alors déjà je salue le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
parce que c'est vrai que entre les
épreuves de cyclisme avec le vélodrome
le vtt et le bmx les épreuves de golf
les épreuves d'équitation il va y avoir
vraiment un territoire qui va vibrer
pendant les jeux ça va être magnifique
et comme cela a été dit en fait encore
une fois le modèle de paris 1024 est
complètement différent des dernières
éditions du jeu on ne va quasiment rien
construire le seul équipement qui est
construit à l'occasion des jeux de paris
1,4 c'est une piscine en
seine-saint-denis tout le reste on
s'appuie sur de l'existant ou sur du
temporaire et ça c'est un dangereux part
de risque voulait dire de dérapages
budgétaires colossaux pas de risque de
dérapage budgétaire pas de risque non
plus de se retrouver que des équipements
qui sont à l'abandon après les jeux tout
ce qui est construit c'est parce qu'il
ya vraiment une utilité et et pour
répondre plus concrètement à la question
à saint quentin en yvelines il ya
effectivement cette colline d'elancourt
qui va être aménagée pour pouvoir
accueillir les épreuves de vtt et qui
sera laissé en héritage pour la
population c'est un accès dans un
domaine qui sera très nature
aux portes de paris pour aller faire du
vélo pour aller se promener et on a
besoin de ces espaces de sport en milieu
naturel en proche banlieue de paris une
de nice-matin denis carot la une de nice
matin on a parlé d'emplois de
recrutement on parle à la une de nice
matin des difficultés de recrutement
notamment dans certains secteurs comme
la restauration ou le btp qui n'arrivent
pas à trouver des candidats à l'embauché
merci denis carot directeur des
rédactions du groupe nice matin dans un
instant des maîtres korkmaz de tv5 monde
sur ce plateau
[Musique]
bonjour des maîtres vous êtes
journaliste à la rédaction de tv5monde
et ce sont les questions internationales
qui vous préoccupe avec l'éthique voilà
ces jeux les questions internationales
ne manquent pas cette nuit la chambre
des représentants aux états unis a voté
une résolution à l'unanimité pour dire
que le cio n'avait pas respecté ses
propres engagements en matière de
protection des droits humains il est
évidemment question de peng shuai vous
même vous avez témoignez votre
solidarité par un tweet c'était le 19
novembre aujourd'hui est ce que vous
êtes rassurez vous sur sa sécurité
écoutez on reste préoccupé on a envie
voilà deux d'avoir des bonnes nouvelles
on sait aussi que c'est un dossier
complexe on sait aussi que il ya
effectivement en coulisses beaucoup
d'interactions et aujourd'hui pas mal
d'organisation quand même en mots se
sont mobilisés et moi je tiens aussi à
saluer que le monde du sport et
solidaire dans ce genre de situation et
et c'est plutôt une bonne nouvelle voilà
moi j'ai marqué je me suis déjà exprimé
sur ce sujet j'ai marqué ma
préoccupation aujourd'hui c'est une
histoire qui est pas terminée on espère
qu'elle va bien se terminer et on peut
rester malgré tout confiant parce que on
sent qu'à une mobilisation y compris en
coulisses pour faire avancer ce dossier
mais ce qu'il faut pas parfois des
mobilisations fortes je pense notamment
à la fédération américaine de tennis
féminin qui a décidé de se retirer
des tournois en chine est-ce que parfois
il ya des situations qui exigent que la
neutralité sportifs soient mises de côté
au profit de principe comme les droits
humains ou la protection on parle de la
grande famille du sport est ce que cette
grande famille n'a pas aussi des devoirs
vis-à-vis de ses membres bien sûr bien
sûr qu'elle a des devoirs et bien sûr
que moi je tiens à saluer encore une
fois le la décision de la fédération de
tennis qui effectivement validé à la
c'est mobiliser sur ce sujet pour pour
peser non dans ce dossier c'est une
décision qui est extrêmement courageuse
et voilà cesser les dirigeants qui ont
ce pouvoir et ce rôle de prendre leur
décision et c'est chaque sport qui doit
gérer son propre avenir de la meilleure
manière possible donc j'ai l'impression
encore une fois sur ce sujet que tout
est mis en oeuvre certains pèse parce
que ils sont directement touchés par ce
que la fédération de tennis féminin
forcément elle est directement impactée
d'autres oeuvres un peu plus en
coulisses c'est le cas du cio
aujourd'hui qui est je pense très
mobilisé sur le sujet et je pense que
c'est complémentaire on va rester sur
ces questions d'éthique
la mairie de paris a exclu total énergie
de la liste des sponsors est-ce que vous
pensez que les entreprises sponsors
doivent aussi répondre à une charte bien
sûr bien sûr qu'aujourd'hui le choix des
entreprises partenaires de ces jeux
doivent s'impliquer dans notre démarche
de réduction des émissions carbone de
transparence et elles le font
aujourd'hui les entreprises fait tomber
si coca cola et bien sûr be bien sûr
bien sûr qu'elles le font sont
l'entreprise
multinationales qui crée des emplois qui
sont dans la transition écologique
également on travaille notamment avec
coca cola aujourd'hui sur la réduction
du plastique à usage unique ils sont
extrêmement mobilisés c'est une
industrie qui est très impacté et c'est
eux aujourd'hui qui innove qui
fournissent à l'ensemble des secteurs
d'activité de nouvelles solutions donc
on travaille sur ces sujets et les
entreprises partenaires de par une 24
elles jouent vraiment le jeu et elle
souhaite vraiment que ces jeux soit
éthiquement responsable alors la
cérémonie d'ouverture aussi oui à la
cérémonie d'ouverture mais juste avant
il y à un syndicat international qui
s'est déplacé à paris et qui s'est
étonné que les chantiers ne soit pas
accessible est-ce que ça jette pas un
peu le doute sur les conditions des
travailleurs est pas et notamment des
travailleurs détachés alors vous savez
on a une charte justement éthiques voilà
qui a vraiment mis en place les bonnes
pratiques
ces chantiers aussi doivent respecter la
sécurité on l'a vu dans le passé
certains chantiers liés au jeu pouvait
être dangereux avec des risques
d'accident aujourd'hui c'est pas le cas
il ya vraiment une éthique très très
forte et la sécurité des chantiers est
garanti donc voilà on maîtrise l'accès à
ces chantiers c'est pas un problème de
transparence c'est un problème de
sécurité une dernière question entre le
faste chinois et le minimalisme japonais
quelle va être la signature artistique
de paris forcément grandiose ou pas
forcément grandiose on a on a un pays
qui est incroyable d'un point de vue
artistique paris 2024 c'est la promesse
du mariage entre le meilleur de la
culture française le meilleur du sport
on a cette ville qui est tellement
envier on a effectivement ce désir
d'organiser cette cérémonie d'ouverture
en ville pour célébrer quelque part
cette ville accueillir ces athlètes du
monde entier dans les meilleures
conditions leur faire vivre une
expérience magique et ne pas créer là
aussi d'un point de vue écologique des
décors artificiels dans un stade juste
pour quelques heures mais s'appuyer sur
un décor qui est réel qui existant qui
est magique
notre dame le louvre la tour eiffel ces
ponts de paris la seine offre un décor
qui est absolument splendide et et je ne
doute pas de la créativité des artistes
français pour nous proposer une
cérémonie inoubliable quelques scoops
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer cette
cérémonie vous le saurez très très très
prochainement mais l'objectif vraiment
c'est inédit c'est la première fois
qu'une cérémonie d'ouverture des jeux
olympiques se tiendra non pas dans un
stade mais en centre ville c'est la
promesse inédite d'offrir la possibilité
à dix fois plus de personnes de
participer y compris gratuitement à
cette cérémonie version vraiment c'est
un spectacle qui est vraiment limité
très réservé à quelques milliers de
personnes là on est sur des échelles à
plus de six cent mille personnes qui
pourraient avoir accès et pour la
plupart gratuitement à cette cérémonie
et vivre un moment magique parce que
c'est dix mille athlètes qui vont
défiler dans paris
quelque part il ya un milliard de
personnes qui vont regarder cette
cérémonie d'ouverture et on espère
qu'ils vont voir une france qui rayonne
c'est la réplique c'est la réputation de
la france qui est en jeu c'est pareil
est une fête exactement c'est la
réputation c'est l'image de la france
est et on a envie que ce soit le
meilleur de la france qui s'exprime à ce
moment là et est donc y aura il y aura
beaucoup d'innovation et de créativité
justement une question il y va y avoir
des chances politique qui arrive est ce
que ça va impacter forcément votre
comité d'organisation alors vous savez
moi je voyais ça vous je travaille sur
ce dossier depuis 2014 et depuis 2014 on
a eu un certain nombre d'élections il ya
eu déjà des élections présidentielles
des élections municipales à on se
rapproche du but quand même on se
rapproche du but mais ce que je veux
dire c'est que ce projet a su démontrer
son autonomie aussi pour continuer à
avancer indépendamment des échéances
électorales puisque vous le savez dans
les acteurs principaux de ce dossier il
y à la maire de paris président du
département y la présidente de la région
il est à présent la république et déjà
trois candidats c'est ça donc il y a
voilà je suis en contact avec réguliers
ils sont très à l'aise pour séparer les
choses et se mettre au service de la
réussite de paris 2024 indépendamment de
leur combat politique et vous le
garantis c'est oui oui non franchement
moi je tiens à saluer leur implication à
la réussite de par une 1024 malgré les
échéances électorales c'est vrai quoi ça
va être très excitant là ces prochains
mois mais je pense que pareille 1024 va
rester en dehors de ce combat politique
vous vous avez approché les politiques
évidemment d'extrêmement près est ce que
vous êtes intéressé par la suite par
alors pas d'une carrière politique au
mans une action politique non c'est pas
du tout à l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui
moi je viens du monde du sport j'ai
aujourd'hui je m'éclate c'est pas le bon
terme probablement mais j'essaie de dire
comme à l'ordre du jour aujourd'hui
c'est ce que j'aurais ancien café un
jour je je je sais pas en fait ce que je
ferai après paris 1024 aujourd'hui je
mets toute mon énergie dans ce projet
c'est un défi immense pour moi c'est une
aventure absolument extraordinaire c'est
complexe quand même de diriger cette
organisation est justement de composer
avec l'ensemble des fédérations
sportives des politiques des grands
dieux que justement je me disais combien
vous avez connu le ministre des sports
ou de mises et les gains ou de
secrétaire d'état beaucoup beaucoup je
ne sais pas si je peux les compter c'est
vrai que c'est quelque chose qu'on peut
potentiellement regretté le fait que
le secteur n'est pas tout mais voilà on
sent bien que c'est pas toujours facile
dans un gouvernement
de poser une stabilité autour du autour
du sport mais globalement encore une
fois je trouve qu'on a un système
français aujourd'hui qui fonctionne
parce que le mouvement sportif et fort
avec ses 180 mille club et ses
fédérations qui au quotidien font du
super boulot et quand même des
collectivités locales qui joue le rôle
aussi dans les territoires et l'état qui
accompagne notamment le sport de haut
niveau françois-xavier lefranc disais
tout à l'heure que vous êtes du béarn
vous vous vivez le béarn pau la capitale
de ce magnifique départements de cette
région ça vous intéresse pas pour une
ambition municipal un jour à pau tony ce
nom et n'en revient à ses racines non
non non c'est pas du tout dans dur
essayer non mes réflexions désolé voilà
j'ai déjà eu des échanges à ce sujet
vous n'êtes pas le premier à me poser la
question mais ce n'est pas loi vous la
pause oui oui on l'a on l'a déjà posée à
plusieurs à plusieurs reprises mais
franchement aujourd'hui mon univers
c'est le monde du sport c'est là que
j'ai l'impression de pouvoir apporter et
donc je mets toute mon énergie dans ce
monde là vous avez appris quoi de ce
parcours exceptionnel à la tête de ce
comité olympique vous personnellement en
tant qu'homme pour moi ce qui est
magique non ce que je vis aujourd'hui
c'est les rencontres je rencontre tous
les jours des gens d'univers très
différents même si mon domaine de
compétence et le monde du sport je suis
obligé aujourd'hui de composer avec des
politiques avec des grandes entreprises
et des grands patrons avec ses
fédérations aussi international et donc
c'est ce mélange permanent de dangereux
très locaux parce que je veux vraiment
que pareille 1024 apporte une différence
localement un peu partout en france pour
renforcer la place du sport dans notre
quotidien mais c'est aussi cette magie
internationale les jeux font rêver la
france fait rêver partout je me déplace
dans le monde les gens se projette vous
auriez vu à tokyo cet été c'était
magique à quel point les gens se disent
aimer mais les jeux en france ça va être
tellement magique et votre voeu pour
2011 2 c'est quoi pour 2022 ou 2024 pour
2022 les deux allées non j'ai pas de
voeux pour 2022 je reste complètement
en dehors tout ça et pour 2024 c'est que
la france réussisse son son défi elle a
rendez-vous notre pays a rendez vous
avec notre histoire et on a une occasion
unique de marquer les esprits et de
rendre les français fiers de leur pays
où voyez vous avez répondu politiquement
à ma question vous pensiez je vous
posais des questions en 2022 à propos
des élections c'était pas le cas oui
c'était des voeux généraux donc j'en
retiens quand même cette appétence pour
la politique merci merci estanguet le
président du comité d'organisation des
jeux olympiques et paralympiques paris
2024 d'avoir été notre invité vous avez
été rare sur les plateaux de télévision
merci de nous avoir sélectionné je sais
que vous avez faire beaucoup maintenant
sans moi merci au revoir des maîtres
merci et paris continue sur tv5 monde
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]